how's it goin brush welcome to a new
let's play this one is called finding
paradise if you know right now you know
you know what pound it that's right
that's right ah this is made by the same
wonderful guy that made to the moon to
the moon is a game I played about five
years ago five five and a half and it
was really this sort of my youtube
singing I think this is one of the first
Let's Plays I did
that wasn't a horror game to the moon of
course and now here we are the
soundtrack is amazing already I don't
know what this game is about I just know
I really want to play this game I really
want to relive those good old days those
2012 pittypat days that we all that we
all appreciate like a fine wine a finest
wine said the whiskey that will take her
back to manly tears are you ready to cry
are you get ready to feel again very
well let's begin finding parodies
Paradiso
this it's made in RPG maker which is
also classic old-school PewDiePie I used
to play so many of these can go that's
that's his name let's hear it
that's my man
oh no it's just I forgot his slapstick
comedy sense of humor thank you oh my
god
oh I remember how funny - the moon was
one of the characters is just better yes
that's it this is a sequel whatever
thank you for censoring it Christian
let's play here that's how you keep
everyone a laugh including the square oh
my god what boys should I do hope you
weren't so big look sometimes it's
either us are they by keeping ourselves
a left now we can be around to stop more
self-inflicted credit casualties later
later later logic and light enlightening
I'm just doing the same voices we should
be arriving at the patients soon I could
use a snack before then do you mind
Wow only you would pack the glove box
full of apple apples
yeah well my nephew decorates the
Christmas tree with them every year and
they may have to eat em for ages apples
on a Christmas tree huh don't you dare
say it don't you mean
and no man something happened in that
laughs assuming my scent hmm oh excuse
me
I'm not hungry anymore
[Music]
so for those of you who that didn't
watch or play to the moon it was
basically a story about two scientists
that could relive memories that's why I
remember it was a while ago and these
are the scientists and we're going to
visit a new patient so we're probably
gonna end up doing the same thing
well check out this red bag why can't be
going working the easy thing because we
are here to visit a dead people not to
get ourselves killed really I couldn't
have
I couldn't tell after the trauma of you
driving like a stunt double I need
reading lessons besides we're visiting
half-dead people very different things
you know what's hurry innkeeper bad way
are they driving them back to the future
car all yours
sumimasen I regret this thank you let's
row
like a cucumber who says that what sense
name if weight nanny
you know cucumber rolls sushi yeah no
that's quite a stretch okay we're
walking am i controlling I am okay
hmm there's a leak in sprinkler
everything hey now you're a rock star
what happened here oh wow
yeah well it's a gym be just like your
life here well looks like thanks potato
but my butt Moss and my booboo is pretty
yeah well she also named you Oh
bazinga ah don't worry boy get your bear
back actually let me take care of this
why what do you mean where I'm telling
you I got this way who helps dr. Watts
all the way hey we're huh is that also
hurts never that's man you doofus ya
dingus it's the new rebel ducks it's a
new rebel doll like three days the
killke is to get attitude and add don't
care and don't care
and like wimpy teddy bear say
Oh justice is served happiness in the
world increased everybody Neal what what
the shopwell pain you did you do but
what do you mean what you just took some
kids stole and kicked it into the water
you could get sued for yeah yay you're
my heroes deprived kid in your face this
is so much stuff yes this is girl
identity get it like a tunic or a vagina
Kristen Channel I'm sorry Jesus dancing
I guess I guess there would be a
different different action if someone
else did it man we should not face Paul
myself so freaking hard man Jebus how
[Music]
Jeepers Creepers all right here we go
what do they mean with half dead people
what is this a Holloway
hello favor
this is dr. Rosaline and dr. Watts from
Sigmund you're actually here yeah hold
on time um are you letting us in I'll
wait outside the door for you what's
there
what was back did you not feel the blast
of ice through the monitor well if she's
the patient's past then she's got a dang
space it's not like we're here to lay
out a picnic all right let's go hello
it's Professor Oak look everyone Dave
sure hello may I help you with something
we can wait till you set that damn bike
my bucks carrying comrade thanks brah
you really get me we share relate to
each other great
okay hey I'm Dave here to fulfill at
someone's dying wish huh how do you know
this is the second time I've seen a
visit from your company this week who is
it this time
[Music]
Colin reads do you know of him the
retired pilot yeah he lives on top floor
very nice go on and give him the happy
ending he deserves probably now I
remember
they didn't they didn't just visit
people's memories it was dying people's
memories to give them a fulfilling death
deep stuff man it's so nostalgic to be
back playing a game like this I mean I
I'm told this is as good as the first
one
spazzes am i right always make the job
so cumbersome depends on the person or
cucumber sim am i right doctor Rosaline
is it and doctor wet ahead yes we're
here yes we're here for calling oh of
course
thank you both for coming right this way
[Music]
okay let's go everybody see what's
inside
Oh what was that was that a little
smirky it's a trap
Admiral Ackbar deuce in the-- Oh Act one
tell me what do you want to change I
don't know maybe the voices oh here we
are everybody in a new room with him a
new atmosphere very nice this is a
quaint place you got he Collins in the
other room come with me
right down to business I like that
do you actually yeah cuz right now I
just really need to put this back Stan
I've been carrying this box forever you
see it's a very heavy box I could go on
about this box for a long time you know
but not too long man
whoa oh there was a guy there damn I
thought they had like those self-opening
once you know nevermind
you must be here for my father yes
you're the patient son yeah I came as
soon as I here where we can talk later
why don't you get set up first the box
look heavy see he gets he gets it yes
but down that box of course where the
hell do I pretend this box sorry in here
okay
where are you two going just stretching
my legs
and breaking my back sorry where do I
here
are you guys ready to get settle set the
Machine down yeah just give us a moment
Yeah right all right all right we're
gonna enter his mind
oof it's the our hair sufficient
why does everyone keep asking me it'll
work fine geesh prefers braces therefore
a power outage of the sub cinematic
proportions look at this [ __ ]
dope right hell yeah
Chris and Shannon huh I guess you got
more stable para grid than her
headquarters that's equally comforting
as it is worrisome
I am fringing therefore Simenson you're
in good hands we do this all the time
too much of the time if you ask me so
you two are for real
what do you mean so someone's been here
before and they failed
can you really fulfill his wish
we'll certainly try our best ma'am but
we always succeed because it would be uh
it would only be in his head though no
like he did not like he'd be able to
tell the difference I can't read anyhow
fess up what is it that he wants yeah
what does he want
he wouldn't tennis he said it doesn't
affect us and we have nothing to well
you're bad well that sounds legit
look Matt that's okay we'll find out
from him soon enough
isn't it also in the paperwork yeah but
who reads that Seth not me
I'm kidding I'm kidding dammit
but seriously where did the fire go it
wasn't in the box
nope guess I might have left it in the
care all right I guess we got time well
the machines booting up anyway who's
gonna fit dr. Watts all the way
rock-paper-scissors- lizard-spock to
decide I'd rather play logic you forgot
it so you go get it the end did what
we're plates back
[Music]
are we are we gonna go I've updated the
system it's practically configuring
itself now
good battle sleep sometime already down
to business huh hey I remember you
yeah it's me doctor it's been a while
says she pretty this although weren't
dr. winters and dr. Lin assigned to this
patient instead yeah but they're
roosters were full at a time so we heard
really hairy heroic
hair heroic Lee volunteered nailed them
I know I'm amazing and reading turnout
they got nothing to do today though hmm
I guess you never know with the timing
no the timing with the nature of your
job anyhow don't mind me I'm just gonna
check on the patient anyhow
okay fine by me all right so is it me or
is it really laggy
[Music]
no it isn't okay is there anything I can
help with I'm just gonna go I'm just
gonna [ __ ] all right let's go Nia Nia
don't forget to get the patient status
monitor from the Collins medical dark
first good idea wouldn't want to be
snoozing when he gives the lung now wait
what am i doing
sorry here this should help okay
Collins heart rate monitor is now
activated press escape or right click to
open trust a little better listening
just hope he doesn't give me tumors okay
connects wirelessly all right okay I
don't have anything right now okay so
something somebody's gonna happen when
we go back to the car you know it Pham
just mark my word I know everything
because I'm the smartest on the planet
they sure must be rich to live in a
house like this
didn't I take the elevator yeah I did
okay man again really I walk for press Q
or miles to switch between characters
what what Nia wasn't kidding this thing
really is configuring itself it does
that now yeah apparently the new pane is
the only upgrade I guess that means I
get some time to snoop around the hairs
cool in the meantime I'll go monitor the
patient like a real doctor I kid I kid
hey you little sneaky [ __ ] I will [ __ ]
you up
I should go get someone okay could you
show me around
yes sir the apartment do you mind
showing me around the police I prefer to
stay here with my husband you damn [ __ ]
oh okay what up what about you
anything I could help with dak I think
you could show me around my apartment
while I'm waiting for my call wait
of course I can we Stefano
will go Asha has joined the party patty
patty patty very nice SS model of a
smurf fix that cut oh is this your dad's
it shows he used to be an airline pilot
today I guess it reminds him of his
roots ah that we got we got a little
hint see we got a little hint see
everybody what else can be fine oh look
it looks seems like an image session
this is my father sold Shella he played
it a lot back in the days but not
anymore it seems maybe because he's
dying Rosaline yeah I guess it's hard in
deviced too much fapping he usually just
placed the scale style it's not exactly
music to be enjoyed all right we got an
aged cello
what is that line what is the line
[Music]
oh my god I got a brain fart
oh yeah little yachties saying blow that
dick like a cello sorry
[Music]
also your fathers or no this is my
mother's she used to lull me to sleep
playing it back in the day intense
intentionally I hope I II basically lil
yachty the rapper confused a cello with
a oh my god I can't even speak today a
flute like Squidward's flute he plays
the what does he play oh my god a
[Music]
clarinet
Squidward place a clarinet you can't
blow a cello everybody and I can't
remember words and he deflected the
whole thing just type whatever you know
what no one cares it was just funny this
is your parents yeah that's then I
remember being embarrassed about that
picture as a kid but it's kind of sweet
that they kept it so away okay
Oh must be hard work growing tropical
plants all the way out here I would I
wouldn't know any better my mother takes
care of them
we had these around the house for as
long as I can remember I guess it's some
kind of family tradition a biscuit
hibiscus rabbits
can we can we swap character by the way
we can where did they go where did they
go
why did it okay all right well let's why
not we had the option that's pretty cool
[Music]
so while here I'd say love it who could
switch to the other character no never
mind
I tried to innovate okay okay
it scares me I'm just gonna go get to
duck down already you didn't die on you
didi Jesus no no sheesh who hired you
Professor Oak Dave what a name what's
your name Dave Yeah right what's your
real name
it's Dave I swear it's my my name is
Dave it's a real name you know so we're
at a hospital I didn't realize I thought
it we were at someone's house I'm an
idiot who's dying dear excuse me ma'am
that coat and tag you are from segment
if you're here then someone's time's up
Coleen reads do you know him
I see he and his wife you're so strong
with my husband and me here everyday
please do your best for him dare you
sound awfully calm about it if I were
your friend I'd be worried
after years of seeing everyone around
you go it's hard not to be but then you
of all people should know that well
excellent it's been great talking to you
I'm gonna go now where's the car there's
a ramp you didn't see the ramp silly me
I hope we take the motorbike later I
hope something happens with the
motorbike are you kidding me open the
there we go
thank you thought it was in the trunk
for some reason it's happening I love
this soundtrack it's so nostalgic to the
to the moon
[Music]
dagnabbit did I leave it at the office
I better take this motorbike to get
there quicker are we calling the office
hello
Roxas me yeah still adding your caller
ID yeah good II understand getting calls
from unknown feels like I'm in a horror
movie you know my bet I'll turn it up
next time
no I love this is space everyday every
time I'm like am I getting curves are
the feds coming after me the
excitement's are endless
um are already anyways look are you
still at the office
I think I left the patient's file on the
printer Oh
okie dokie pokey Loki just give me a
moment
[Music]
yeah hey you got the file even I think
it's I think I forgot it backache you
ought not even [ __ ] don't worry
I can't obtain she's gonna find it and
send over a scam okay just take care of
it
Wow this job is really busting my Nets
did you find it reps yeah it was just
sitting on your table after all great
just scan it and wait my table you're in
my room yep
you asked me to get the files right I
meant from the printer in the lobby how
did you get in my room anyhow I locked
it Oh a girl's got her ways okay look
just get out of there and find a scam
would you and don't touch anything I
just organized it yep be up on it she's
not gonna leave you Rach what oh my god
Vishnu God is always my dad oh my god Oh
your guys got everything else you need
yeah if it's configuring the machine
baton hey how's the weather out there
what is it nice out for a drive I get
sip neato
I think I'll just come over and get you
the file in person then what why just
scan it and send over a copy well we've
got no patience today and it's boring
here anyway anyhow don't worry I'll get
there before you guys are done see ya
after him wait Rox
dagnabbit that's what I should have said
damn it if only I had a broader
vocabulary things would be different
hey we're here now DAG nabbit you guys
see that cliff we post him alone never
mind then damn dang it why is the toilet
people never on the dispenser
marzia never puts it on the dispenser
and i hope she hears me I mean I I'm
gonna die one day they'll thank me for
the unsung hero but I am I'm thinking
you know Rosaline I salute you put the
damn toilet paper where it belongs
I'm not some animal Wow this is truly an
immersion of experience we're putting
toilet paper oh we're back here all
right I think we're done
[Music]
yes about car do you mind telling me
about your husband why won't you be
going into his head to see for yourself
but well we're background and
perspectives could always help I don't
know what I could tell you that you
won't be able to see how does she know
it's not like she knows what it's like
if they had this equipment I'd be like
what are you seeing here huh
you okay Edgar am i waking you up am I
too loud for you yeah shut the hell up
roach and you're sleeping on my lap so
cute all right let's go upstairs cuz we
haven't done that and let me talk a
little less loud for a joker I haven't
seen many apartment with multiple floors
most of the flow is for maintenance we
just go got a little storage room cadet
sorry about the mayor seems like they'd
been doing doing a bit of clean air what
sorry about the mess seems like they
should have done some cleaning huh seems
like the missed one I think I reckon I
said bicker it's been around for quite a
while my dad kept it taped up I guess it
didn't want to throw it away
mysterious book yeah it's seal but he
doesn't want anybody reading in her it
must be his diary
well under normal circumstances I'd say
leave it alone for privacy sake but he
did sign up to become your clan so I
don't know
hell yeah let's read that [ __ ] back
there is a chance that he might help the
mission
[Music]
there's nothing in this huh it's nothing
but stacks of empty pages glued to the
span what that makes no sense what
they're a wrinkled - that's right it's
been around for a jester maybe whatever
was under faded
these aren't receipts but I guess it's
possible either way there's not much I
can do with this I'll put it back let's
keep moving all right very good
Oh Oh actually there's something else
that might help you prepare
ooh Oh what is it yeah the family photo
album kiss my back a physical photo
album in this day and age feels like
even turn to - if I open it it's great
but I guess they liked having something
they can catch a a look throw it if you
want I go check on my father
I should go get the Machine ready - my
colleague will be back soon but I'll
check this out for a bit first very well
they will go sayona
arrivederci goodbye I look at these
pictures that's adorable
oh that's so sweet
Cabaye Disney
[Music]
so they played together instruments
wonderful dr. Watson how are we doing he
good got my partner how about the file
you said Brock's is slimming the schemes
she said she's delivering it in person
for some reason why that's wasting both
of our time in hurts hurts mostly
Harwich mostly we can stiff stack still
I mean how I know she is a bit cucumbers
in the hand and oh wow what a what a
wonderful way to say someone is an idiot
whoa language either anyway won't worry
about her looping this later shall we
start
alright I read that wrong just get the
patient equipment
[Music]
hmm never mind we'll talk later your
helmet is on the reclaimer we're all set
we're gonna go inside we're gonna go
inside boys
yeah yay Virtual Reality commence memory
traversal ready wait aspetta
before you begin could you tell me what
you you'll be doing in there we're going
through his memories to grant him his
last wish death yes I do know that but
yeah what would you actually be doing
well no time to explain
look although your father's condition is
stable for now
he is an attainment I can't say for
certain but we have about a day's time
to work with sorry it didn't mean to
hold you hit I don't know what's going
to happen in there but good luck Lux for
Lawry's we're professionals each a twig
could you see you in the other side
[Music]
see I should have done all the sudden
sound effects patient is stable and
ready
initializing memory traversal sequence
in three two what yep pretty good pretty
good sound effect thank you
oh we entering the first memory oh yeah
there was a time line all right
this could be callings last accessible
memory yeah and check out if the
reigning heavy sleeper Champa check out
the ring every sleeper jab over here
leave that memory of her alone she's not
our coin by the way I want to ask our
leader
what's with the helm you put on your
patient the equipment it looked
different
oh I just removed that casing during
maintenance that's all then why didn't
you put it back hey that reminds me did
you know I added a new feature new
feature be her never mind forget I asked
[Applause]
character customization Wow
what why to made it I can't even see
them to made a pattern that can only be
one yes just why well I figured if we're
gonna spend so much time working here we
might as well travel instead we if did I
say we sorry
I meant oh wait that's exactly what I
mean
dad you're it
oh my mammy you had long flowing locks
well not any merit that's not too bad
none of these are bad yes
what hey don't blame me it's a system
that choose it for you are they talking
about me right now well let's just sit
down to me you know hey hey I can hear
you
well well don't insult the system that's
not cool
whatever I'm changing back oh come on it
was a lot of work to implement besides
you owe me for what happened at the tofu
party last night humor me for a bit you
did take a solid hit for me at the toefl
party fine I'll keep the look until we
find : sweet nice axe by the way yeah
I'm okay with the shocks all right
current memory position in time can be
viewed by moving the mouse forward at
the top of the screen okay oh what's
turned off oral interaction before we
wake around okay after oh that I'm
surprised we didn't already
what I don't remember this okay we're
we're fading back in goddamn [ __ ]
sleeping hard dog what knocked her out
it's not polite to stare
Shh and she didn't seem to like us
before where do we go I don't know I
don't remember like where you're
supposed to do your kid game
[Music]
oh here we go oh there is isn't it gonna
add a scam calling Oh what this is an
astable copy let's find one we can talk
to what does I mean we have to find
another version of inside oh there we go
okay man I'm too good at video games
honestly you are lucky you're watching
the best let's player on YouTube without
a shadow of a damped should we go up sir
yeah he must be upstairs maybe working
on the book
watch me be right watch me be right look
at this 10 out of 10 where I [ __ ] I will
sometimes you're unlucky and it happens
to everyone
one moment let me just check the book
chains how do I bet though that I
thought bad about that huh
oh now would you read the book it's
still full of books here you must have
cleared it very recently then get it
yeah well I checked this place in
reality it was empty except for one
Outlook which isn't here actually Oh
speak okay interesting so maybe we
should recheck some of the memories like
the flower perhaps see see if there's
anything well nothing
okay well let's let's exit here then
nothing more to do here I suppose
[Music]
whoa edger
ah pretty sure the hole didn't look like
this
dude dude so old he can't even remember
his own hand but it's in the machine
supposed to autocorrect these kind of
spatial inconsistencies yes of course
well oh hey look ha ha what is happening
dude didn't the hold me look like this I
remember it like this target acquired
let's go bazinga ah I thought you forgot
him all right thanks turning on entity
interaction I think let's go
full-on attack pokeball go
I do remember that was like poke balls
in the first one calling Jesus what up
my name is dr. Emma Rosaline I am a
memory traveler soul specialist at
segment Corp and my colleague here is
dr. a headband doctor man ha ha you are
dr. Neil watts how did you know your
nametag
oh this isn't what it looks to be is it
yes calling your procedure has started
good it's not just me then something
felt off about this place it's as if I'm
both here and far away at once either
this is where I think I am or my head is
going down here faster than I thought
more like both actually Hey very Nick my
wife and son how are they handling it
they're there right
they're there right yeah but they aren't
prancing around that's for sure although
given the circumstances I guess I'd be
worried if they were listen there's
something there's not a lot of time and
it's best if we get started you are the
most recent slice of calling that we can
load up and the only relatively reliable
version that we can interact with for
info so I hope you can exist us in
completing the mission of course why
would I know
good I'll keep your state saved so we
don't need to have this conversation
again
just let us save on this day yes your
highness
now in order to help you relive your
life here's here to fulfill your last
wish
we are gonna backtrack through your
marriage to connect your Tam lay and and
then we'll be able to transfer your
desire all the way to your younger self
and run the algorithm for you to live
your life here all over again
to fulfill your wish anyhow colleague we
need your help to jump between memories
we need mementos there are the items of
importance that you connect one memory
with another do you have one here that
we could jump with we're work slow dad
we still don't even know what his wish
is what is it that you aren't anyway :
[Music]
actually I think I can answer both of
your question with this it's his sigmund
country
the text is rather blurry but ocean
initial momentum sweat let's move
[Music]
well fish momentous parry of shadows by
itself since it's so reasoned but the
next one won't be so easy
we'll need to charge it up first okay
[Music]
oh yeah I remember this is puzzle bit
memories go the far there's one linked
together
all right what did I do it her oh I did
it everyone all right
thanks we might come back for your help
again
okay what was in the momentum what is
his story why does he want don't worry
wait a minute this place
it's a Sigmund's guesthouse ah where
they wine and dine the gives our into
signing up for this service where they
wine and dine the geezers in signing up
for this service sure been awhile since
I visited looks a bit different from
when I was last here too let's check it
out
requires one memory orb to proceed okay
I guess we can find that
sorry how
what oh okay oh okay okay okay we go
here I didn't see it I'm stupid what are
you doing outside in the cold mr. Reid's
your appointment is about ready please
right this way hey we got an orb
everybody look at that that is a nice
orb everybody hey we enter before him
what a loser
welcome to Sigmund Corp Guest House
please have a seat in our living room ow
[Music]
we detected a memento oh we got to
charge it are we good to go why don't
you sit back and enjoy some tea first
you come a long way to get here I need
to get back home soon I just like to
inquire about your service very wet
someone will be here to get you very
shortly there's so much to the world
isn't there much more than one could
explore in one single lifetime say would
it be nice to visit where you always
wanted to go I've already been there
once you put it down yeah another
momento cacao you know I've been rather
impressed laughs oh well back in the
days you kept on yelling dumb juvenile
ADIZ when shooting the barrels but
recently or whatnot it's been rather
Pleasant and professional Oh hmm I liked
how I did it instead great all right
we're looking for one more
this photo is taken from this stage
perspective accelerating huh not many
people get to experience what it's like
to be famous we sure get a lot of
requests for that so if it floats your
boat can consider it done Oh we'll see
oh so they can make anything happen I
see by the way being famous means
fuck-all
it's an illusion depicted by the media
that it's something great it's [ __ ]
not there's nothing great about it if we
don't do another one of these I'm gonna
take a nap it's not so bad at least we
get it done fast and go home early come
on we got to find one more up the stairs
[Music]
give us the momentum you see our service
is quite simple you tell us your wish
and we make it happen
fame wealth own reach goals and secret
desires you name it rear Jenny Colin
what is your wish so if I understand
this correctly you're saying I can't
wish for more wishes you know I've done
and seen a lot in my left hand I've been
to where I once thought I'd never be
seeing what I once thought I'd never see
but in the blink of an eye suddenly
there's no more tape and I find myself
here just like everyone else I walk
through these doors and I realized that
there's still this empty feeling inside
me I don't mean to be ungrateful to the
life I had but I just want to feel like
I've done enough in this world before I
go you know I want to say I lived a
happy life and I want to feel like I
have few regrets but somehow after all
that I still can't that's why we're here
Colin just give us a word and we'll make
it rain tell us your regret what is it
you want us to fix
regrets I don't know what to tell you
for the regrets but I can tell you what
I want
a lot of skittles I never had enough
skittles I just want you to make me live
that fulfilling life I want it but I
want you to do it without changing
anything I've been through what Collin
you're being way too complicated you
don't want us to change anything
calling changing things is what we do we
change things and we make them better
that's why you come to us so we can make
it better we can solve your problems
everything you wanted but couldn't have
in this life we can give you a chance to
get it but if you want to get something
you need to give up something so I ask
again what is your last wish very well
I want you to give me a fulfilling life
while changing as little as possible and
if you have to change something please
just keep the memories of the life my
with my family intact so you want to
wave specifically from the contract with
something like that I hope you know
there are no guarantees of result I'm
aware it's settled then I'll put our
best people on it thank you that's all I
ask what do you mean that's all you ask
Jesus try not to change anything and we
are free reign over these feet
what kind of life's wishes that I don't
even know where to start
hey wave severs the important thing here
is that the bus said we'll put our best
people on it we're their best people
ever yeah actually about there never
mind okay I'm good let's get the
momentum all right oh one more thing
please don't tell my family I don't want
to think I'm not content with how things
are well mission failed
[Music]
alright let's break this momenta
kamehameha
another one of these sometimes only the
Kurama mentor rings about what there you
go it's a clam okay
climb it up buddy I better get that
I better head out before I forget yeah
take the side pups it's a hat with a
headache you've been getting you should
be more careful of the wind I had been
telling him that for ages he never
listens all right all right I'll wear it
if it stops this multi-directional
nagging look at me I'm a fricking pimp
with his [ __ ] on dawg hey it's been a
while since your thing with Pam didn't
work out listen I was talking with my ol
colleague the other day he's got a
daughter named Janice you're saying
she's single in look thanks but I think
I just really need to focus and Mecca
here I got this new accent okay came out
of nowhere so you guys gonna go back to
feeding the Ducks or something well you
wouldn't have to resort to that if you
visit us more often your little bastard
ah but that had this 100% cuttin well
all right you're off the hog
drive safe dear we'll stay here and keep
being overlord of the Ducks bimah bimah
and plight of you not for the duck thing
but but like you know what they mean
what's the hell is with the docs don't
stay out too long at this time of year
a kid needs to make us a grandchild
what's wrong with Jenny anyway probably
nothing but you know how it is when you
were young didn't your parents try to
push people unto you sure did
it was awkwardly it was awkward and
Forrest hmm sucked all the chemistry out
of it for me as well
what are you doing I'm texting Jenny's
input to set Timo's don't do that he's
driving do it after he gets out good cop
make sure to include some pictures too
she has a nice rack the good ones wood
lining coming from this side no words
there we go
okay gonna do a save there really enjoy
being back in to the moon extremely
nostalgic I hope you guys enjoy it as
well please do leave a like if you want
more let me know if you want more I
would love to keep playing this and yeah
if so I'll see you tomorrow stay awesome
breasts